hey this is this is almost beyond parody
um
donald trump's former chief of staff
mark meadows
is being investigated for voter fraud
and mark meadow's wife appears to have
incorrectly illegally fraudulently
filled out voter registrations you've
got to see this this is just
unbelievable after arguing for you know
six months that democrats were going to
cheat and all of these voter
registration things all this different
stuff and then claiming the election was
stolen by joe biden
salon is now reporting mark meadows
under investigation for alleged voter
fraud in north carolina
macon county d.a
a meadow's ally
refers potential prosecution of trump's
ex-chief of staff
to the attorney general this is
unbelievable
meadows who helped spread trump's
debunked voter fraud claims
may have committed voter fraud himself
in 2020.
trump's former top aide and his wife
debbie registered to vote in what has
been called a dive trailer in a remote
rural area meadows does not appear to
have spent a single night there
according to the report local news
outlet wral later reported that meadows
and his wife voted via absentee ballots
in north carolina in 2020 sparking a
state investigation state attorney
general josh stein's office asked the
state bureau of investigation to
investigate alongside the board of
elections at the conclusion we'll review
their findings
um
this he
he seems to have done the thing
which they said everybody else on the
democratic side is doing meadows listed
the scally mountain mobile home address
in a voter registration field that asks
for the residential address where you
physically live
mark and debbie meadows sold their prior
north carolina home when meadows joined
the trump administration meadows is also
registered to vote in virginia where
they own a condo
um the former owner of the mobile home
told wral they had rented the property
to meadows family but said the former
trump aide never spent a night down
there and that meadow's wife only stayed
for a night or two
then there's a report
in the washington post about deborah
meadows debra meadows appears to have
filed
three false voter forms
look at this
look at this on her one-stop application
provided this week by the north carolina
board of elections to the fact-checker
debra meadows certified she resided in a
14 by 62-foot mountaintop mobile home
for at least 30 days even though she did
not live there at the top of the form is
a notice that quote fraudulently or
falsely completing this form is a class
1 felony uh oh
this form is the latest in a string of
revelations concerning the former chief
of staff
who echoed trump's claims false claims
of election fraud in 2020
and his wife
the new yorker first reported that mark
and debra meadows submitted voter
registration forms listing their home as
a mobile home with a rusted metal roof
that sold for a hundred and five
thousand dollars even though they never
live there
north carolina officials announced that
meadows is under investigation for
potential fraud now this this is like
the key part here
um the fact checkers reporting shows
that in 2020 debra meadows signed three
forms a voter registration form an
absentee ballot request for her husband
and the one-stop application that warned
of legal consequences if falsely
completed and signed she also cast a
ballot in a 2020 primary runoff using an
address that was no longer valid for
voting
meadows appears to have signed a voter
registration form he did not vote in the
primary guys the calls are coming from
inside the house you know it has been a
decade now at least of republicans
regularly accusing others of the things
they are actually doing and it's almost
like a technique it's it's like an
investigative technique for us if we
hear from republicans
that hillary would not be trustworthy
with sensitive private and classified
information or email
we should at least explore
whether it is they who cannot be trusted
and of course we find out jared's using
private email for white house business
ivanka's using private email from white
for white house business trump is
spilling secrets to a russian spy
recruiter in the oval office trump is
eating papers
flushing papers 10 to 15 times
reportedly
if they're saying that democrats are
doing it we should at least investigate
whether it is actually them that are
doing it when they say well
we are going to uh have democrats do all
sorts of voter fraud
well we should be really careful that
you're going to do the voter fraud and
that you're gonna spread lies about the
election and um it has essentially come
down to listen
the election was we know the election
was rigged because because we did it
uh that that is where we have
fundamentally fallen here and meadows
should be investigated his wife should
be investigated and listen i know that
none of us if you've been paying
attention to the two-tier justice system
in this country for the last decade
you would be
reasonably
situated
to question whether mark meadows will
face any consequences regardless of what
he did even if he did it even if they've
got him dead to rights
it's it's not super likely he's going to
face any real consequences meanwhile
there are people who just accidentally
voted that they weren't supposed to they
they were like i'm probably you know
parole or there were certain situations
often low-income people
who uh sometimes end up in prison you
know so we it is this entire voter fraud
thing is not only illuminating because
they are the ones doing it but they
accuse everybody else of doing it
but it's also notable because it exposes
that two-tier justice system where
despite the people getting caught
continuing to be mostly republicans
the penalties are almost completely
absent it
it's depressing i'm with you
but we should understand that if they
are repeatedly talking about something
we should very closely look at whether
they themselves are the ones doing it
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below